from Brussels back to Britain and object
Colchester and collective is busy with
the Prime Minister this is a car park
add in a factory and that is a
conservative bus where we will be
talking still about the situation in the
Mediterranean a suspect whilst the Prime
Minister looks at a company that makes
massive fans and you can see there that
they've got the hive is ready it's
always got to be high there's before you
go into a factory we are in Colchester
which is a Lib Dem seat Bob Russell has
over 6,000 majority but the Tories
clearly in this election are assuming
that no lib dem is safe so here's the
Prime Minister arriving in Colchester
having flown back from Brussels and then
somewhere else in between link it in
between is that right to thank you yeah
see he's a busy man he's a busy man and
so this is where the Prime Minister is
factory you'd be amazed by the logistics
that goes on when it comes to getting
the conservative team the Prime Minister
around here is the Tory bus reversing
the house has done an eight-point turn
in the next car park but you have to say
just like two feet
we're now in clacton which is the Lions
Den it might not look like it but this
is of course when douglas Carswell has
won a seat for you kit not the cancer
the Tories getting it back but clearly
the prime minister wanted to come here
to talk about the east of england so now
the prime minister is heading back home
and tomorrow there'll be another group
of marginal constituencies he said the
last time he was here in this clacton
constituency well actually imprint
Anansi to be specific it was with a
girlfriend he played tennis he had a
swim and then he said she don't